our Twitter question today we asked you
will you buy an Apple watch the first
answer I never buy Apple first
generation products I learned that from
the first I pen second answer Apple has
a large fan base that will buy the watch
and probably the highest NPS in the
world if it's useful it will spread
finally they've no idea what MPs is it's
not our motor score what is it net
promoter score it's the measure of how
much someone is willing to promote a
product or tell their friends to buy a
product which is what most companies use
today especially consumer companies to
gauge how satisfied people are with the
product which is back to the previous
conversation I guarantee you your
airline friends will have a very low and
PS score somewhere along the lines of
cable companies and most importantly to
our conversation from earlier the banks
okay interesting are you certain final
answer pretty clear here no people will
buy it just because it has an apple logo
but it is just not practical I disagree
with that I think the frictionless thing
is cool i look forward to that i'm gonna
fish for that i'm gonna to i mean we're
back a hundred years with us with the
pocket watch every time you take our
phone the most interesting thing that
i've been thinking about with the
swatches i've seen a lot of people
complain like oh my God we're already
sitting at dinner with the family and
everybody's going like this now do I
need another device to go like this all
day and what I'm wondering and what I'm
actually looking for in the watch is
maybe an opportunity to not do this as
much I'd love to see a different form
factor make us look at our phone less
and be present more and if app
developers can do that I think it'll be
really intramuros been brilliant thank
you so much as always chris chris aunty
thank you